an international search and rescue team
is racing to find a missing submersible
carrying five people who disappeared
during a trip to the deep sea remains of
the Titanic shipwreck
operated by Ocean Gate Expeditions the
submersible called the Titan launched
from St John's Newfoundland on Sunday
but nearly two hours into its roughly
eight-hour Expedition the craft lost
contact with a research vessel on the
surface
our crews are working around the clock
to ensure that we are doing everything
possible to locate the Titan the Titan
which was carrying four crew and a pilot
weighs 21 000 pounds and can travel more
than thirteen thousand feet beneath the
surface the vessel is designed to
sustain 96 hours of emergency oxygen as
of Tuesday afternoon the people aboard
had about 40 hours of the oxygen left
according to the U.S Coast Guard it all
depends on your oxygen conservation
activities if you get people to achieve
a low metabolic oxygenation practice
then you can stretch that oxygen out and
that increases your chances of survival
the search involving aircraft and
surface vessels was intensifying about
900 miles east of Cape Cod near the site
of the Titanic wreckage this is a
complex search effort which requires
multiple agencies with subject matter
expertise and specialized equipment the
challenging part is getting there and of
course the planning you got to know the
environment down there the five
passengers aboard include British
Aviator and Explorer Hamish Harding who
went to space on a blue origin rocket in
2022 shazada wood a member of One of
Pakistan's richest families and his son
suleimandawud Paul Henry najeola a
French explorer who is considered a
leading Authority on the Titanic and
Stockton Rush the founder and chief
executive of Ocean Gate
the company was founded in 2009 and
began offering tours to the Titanic's
Rack in 2021 in a 2022 CBS news report
Rush provided a tour of the Titan and
what he described as its off-the-shelf
components I got these from a camper
world we run the whole thing with this
game controller
[Music]
the expedition's aim was to take high
definition photos and video of history's
most famous shipwreck and capture data
to track the ship's Decay you're dealing
with a surface search and a subsurface
search and frankly that makes it an
incredibly complex operation